new research from The Ohio State
University shows that selfie takers
chronic selfie takers you know who you
are are pretty much the most
narcissistic people on the planet
that's right they say people that
overload the internet with lots of
selfies are more likely to exhibit
psychopathic or narcissistic qualities
that don't know we've got some more info
for you men who reported taking extra
time to edit selfies with Photoshop or
other programs before posting them
online also exhibited high levels of
self objectification which means they
liken themselves to sex objects instead
of people a mode of thinking that can
lead to such problems as eating
disorders and depression I've talked
about a divine she's like I am so over
the selfie thing I hope that I hope that
I can live up to this that I've taken my
last selfie there might be a situation
where I'm alone and like an alien is
there or something and I got to do it
but pretty much we're all taking selfies
while there's other people there that
could potentially take the picture and
usually better I'm over the selfie I
believe in this narcissistic thing you
know that we're all staring our phones
and then we immediately wait for it to
watch the likes roll in and it's all
crazy and self-absorbed
go I think it stems from certain amount
of loneliness
most people when I see them posting
selfies I understand you're saying
sometimes there's other people that
could take the photo for them so if
you're in a public place and you're
taking selfie like at lay Eiffel Tower
and you're taking a selfie but looked at
also can be born of inherent loneliness
too you want other people to see your
experience and experience it with you
which is a little bit narcissistic but
at the same time there you're not
interacting with other people to do it
so I know everyone likes to make fun of
people like oh they're taking selfies
but I always when I see someone posting
a lot of selfies I always want to reach
out and go like oh my god are you okay
someone to talk to you Jeannie oh yeah
you're it's like look at me help I like
I'm alone why don't you ever take a hike
with another person exactly maybe yeah I
think there are a handful of cases in
which a selfie is fine right if you had
Halloween makeup on great take a selfie
if you just got a crazy haircut and you
want to share it with the world and let
everyone know you did fine if you are
passing by the presidents and it's
behind you take a selfie do that if
you're Ellen DeGeneres at the Oscars and
you're surrounded by twenty a listers
take it yeah I think the problem is when
people take it when there's nothing new
there's nothing new about their
situation they're at home
you've already posted 20 other selfies
with their cats like don't do another
one there's literal like no other more
literal display of narcissism than a
selfie when there's nothing to report as
like newsworthy that person you should
call them because that means they were
sitting if you know somebody in your
life that's chronically taking selfies
home alone in their house or just alone
I mean instead of this attitude where
people make fun of that person and be
like oh you're such a narcissist or so
you're so into yourself that really
makes me want to get in touch with that
person and be like because I mean maybe
I know what that's like if nothing
better into your like rules we'll take a
picture it's a way of reaching out to
the world and going this is a reminder
that my face still exists please talk to
me yes so I'm so on that you know I post
my boyfriend and fiance guy I do some
stuff with he he's an incredible chef
incredible chef so I'm constantly taking
pictures of his food and then I do some
ex-pro too and a little highlights or
whatever it is and I'm constantly doing
it and and I realize how silly it is
it's like instead of immediately I get
the meal in front of me and my first
inclination is to take the picture now
he's working on like a book about it so
we're trying to do something with some
of the pictures but removing that like
you know it's all taking us out of the
experience you guys find that when
you're doing this that no one's sort of
living through everything I was just in
Times Square and there were literally
people with the selfie stick have you
seen this thing I mean there are people
that are just walking around with the
selfie stick in front of them staring up
and you know people that are clearly
from other countries that have never
been there before in Times Square I
think again there's exceptions to that
rule right if it something that you
created like a creation of yours food
art whatever it might be like take a
picture of it I don't know if it's like
you're out at a restaurant someone else
made it for you for no other reason then
you want to show everyone what you're
eating like again a bit narcissistic
that people would care but but yeah I
mean I I was always a chronic picture
taker like I would I had the newest
digital camera always and I would just
you know obsessively take pictures when
I was out with friends now I have like
10,000 photos in my photo they're like
some of the most incriminating stuff
ever like my Harvard classmates will
never be able to get elected any public
office because of the pictures that I
took out and I borrow your phone not on
the laptop no okay
that's gonna get confiscated at somebody
I'm sure but I think that there's I
don't think it takes you out the
experience because then you can go back
and relive it and with better memories
of it than if maybe you had just been
experiencing it with one set of senses
yeah all right what do you think
are you a chronic selfie taker are you
taking selfies right now while watching
is if you take a selfie while watching
this and then tweeted at me I will
retweet you and then I'll feel better
about myself you'll feel better about
yourself
etc etc let us know in the comments
right down below